[Music]
[Music]
i can't think about anything else but
her
i miss
you're chasing ghosts she is
gone and there's nothing that you can do
i think i know you you the ranger with
the dead wife what did you say texas
ranger's wife fights a bullet down by
the border
you got a sad story i get that and i got
your back that is my job
but i need to know that you have
[Applause]
are under mine it's about your brother
he requested the drone footage of the
night that emily died
you hear me when i say this you will
lose everything
walker series premiere thursday january
21st stream free next
day only on the cw app codel walker
texas ranger he recently lost his wife
[Music]
it wasn't your fault wasn't it though
you're the ranger with the dead wife
what did you say
guess you can protect her huh i can't
stop
she is gone some things don't add up
you are chasing ghosts i can't think
about anything else
but her walker series premiere thursday
january 21st
stream free next day only on the cw app
you